- Hi everyone.
Good evening and welcome to our
Franke Program, Mapping
as Knowing Lecture Series.
We have a wonderful talk this evening.
I first wanted to say thanks
to all of you for joining in
and much as we would have
loved to see you all in person
and have a lovely reception afterwards
at the moment we're gonna have to make do
with just the company and the talk.
I wanted to remind you that
we are recording this event
so we request you all to mute your videos.
And you can submit questions
to the speaker today
through the chat feature.
And so we'll be reading
questions off the chat.
And I wanna start off by
thanking our benefactors,
Richard and Barbara Franke,
who's support of both
the program materially
and of course the intellectual support
is really deeply appreciated.
They plan on joining us.
I am not sure if they
have entered our room yet.
For today's talk, I'm utterly delighted
to introduce our distinguished speaker
in this ongoing series,
mapping as knowing.
And our speaker this evening
is Professor Frank Snowden.
Professor Snowden is
the Andrew Downey Orrick
Professor Emeritus of History
and History of Medicine.
And he'd received his PhD from Oxford.
He is the author of many
critically acclaimed books,
including Violence and Great Estates
in the South of Italy: Apulia 1900 - 1922
which was published in 1984.
The Fascist Revolution
in Tuscany, 1919-1922,
published in 1989.
Naples in the Times of Cholera in 1995
and The Conquest of Malaria
in Italy, from 1900-1962,
a book that he published in 2006.
You might wonder why I'm
reading out all these.
This is just vicarious
pleasure from just imagining
the wonderful fieldwork experiences
that he must have had in
Apulia, Tuscany, Naples
and now that we're all stuck at home,
I was really nostalgically
looking at this list
and wondering how what
it must really be like
to travel again.
His book, The Conquest
of Malaria was awarded
the Gustav Ranis Prize
from the MacMillan center at Yale in 2007
as the best book on an international topic
by a member of the Yale faculty,
an honor that you all
are probably aware of,
and the Helen and Howard Marraro Prize
by the American Historical Association
as the best work on Italy in any period.
He's the recipient of many
awards, accolades and honors.
And I will just mention
one in the interest
of not holding you all up
from hearing him this evening.
And that is the 2008 Welch Medal
from the American Association
for the History of Medicine.
He is the author of a brand new book
which is extremely topical and timely
and has been very influential
since its publication
just earlier this year.
And the book is titled
Epidemics and Society:
From the Black Death to the Present
and this is published by Yale Press.
It's wonderfully written book
and I strongly encourage you to buy it.
As you can see from the record
of his scholarship and his research
he has deep insights on epidemics
and our ability or lack
of ability to manage them.
(clears throat)
Today he will be talking to
us about maps and epidemics.
In particular, lessons
for the current pandemic
for COVID-19.
He also teaches undergraduate
and graduate courses
in Italian history, European
social and political history,
and the history of medicine.
Before I hand over to him
I just wanted to remind you
about a couple of upcoming Franke events.
The next talk in our series on
the mapping as knowing series
is going to be by the
musicologist Victor Coelho
and that's going to be next term.
You will all hear about it.
We'll send you the poster
and details later on.
I was very excited to announce that
the Franke Program had announced
a contest called Eureka
which in light of the pandemic,
we have had to reimagine
and we have re-imagined
it as a new project
which we call Learning by Doing
which we are launching next week.
It is a set of simple
science experiments for kids
that they can do with their parents.
And we are planning to offer
videos of these experiments.
We'll be collecting ideas
and we have a website.
So please watch out for a website
www.learningbydoing.academy.
I will share further
information in just a minute.
Without further ado, I
would like to turn it over
to Professor Snowden to speak to us.
We are eagerly waiting to learn from you
about maps and
epidemiology, in particular,
lessons for this COVID-19
which has completely destabilized
our world at the moment.
Professor Snowden.
- Thank you so much.
I thank all of you for
joining me this afternoon
and it's a great pleasure to be here.
I wish also to thank the
Whitney Humanity Center
and the Franke Lecture
Series for inviting me
and especially I want to thank you
for the very generous introduction.
I was going to say a
word or two about myself
but I think that the
organizers know me much better
than I know myself.
So since that's no longer
necessary I'll just begin.
And I'd like to say what my
plan is first this afternoon.
What I'd like to do is to
consider the relationship
between historical map
making on the one hand
and the emergence of
epidemiology on the other.
My idea in particular is
to begin by considering
one of the most influential
maps in the history of medicine,
the famous map of the
London-based physician, John Snow.
He did in fact, draw two maps
and they've been called maps that changed
the history of the world.
They helped to unlock the mystery
of Asiatic cholera as a disease.
These were maps that also
related to the pandemic
that afflicted London in 1854.
The first, and I can
perhaps show that now,
is a map that was a detailed
map of a single neighborhood,
the neighborhood of Soho in London.
The second map is a map, that's the one,
is the map of that I
won't actually be showing
but I will talk a little bit about it.
It details the relationship
between the disease, cholera
and the provision of water to South London
by two different water companies.
Having then explored
what Snow demonstrated
by his cartography,
I wanna leap forward in time to COVID-19
thinking about what we can
learn about the epidemiology
of this pandemic by
considering a series of 239,
don't panic I'm not planning
to show you them all,
but 239 maps produced
by the United States
government in the 1930s.
Maps that impose very important questions
about the nature of the Corona virus
and the ways in which it is laid bare.
The way that social injustice itself
is a very important pathway
through which this disease
is making its way through our country.
Now, let's remember when
we talk about John Snow,
what the understanding of Asiatic cholera
was at the time when he
was carrying out his work.
At that time, the international
medical profession
had two different views
regarding what cholera might be.
The dominant view was
one that was the view
that this was not a contagious disease,
it was an anti contagionist view.
It argued that cholera was not transmitted
from person to person in any sort of way
but in some undefined way
it was produced by a poison
in the air called the miasma.
The miasma originated
from decaying organic matter and filth.
And the miasma arose as a deadly effluvium
that susceptible people
inhaled and fell ill.
In England it was very much
common by medical authorities
to refer to malaria, that is bad air,
or they also talked about
the filth theory of disease.
That is to say whole
categories of disease,
including cholera, were
thought to be non-contagious.
Contagionism, the idea
of an infectious disease,
was a minority view but the one
that John Snow himself espoused.
He believed that cholera was not
a miasmatic disease at all
but was transmitted person to person
via the medium of contaminated water.
In 1849 he had already written a book
on the mode of communication of cholera
before his famous maps.
And there he outlined his
objections to miasmatism
and proposed instead what he saw
as the more plausible
interpretation of contagion.
But he lacked convincing evidence
and couldn't suggest
the mechanisms above all
that were involved in
his idea of transmission.
So the major outbreak of 1854
provided him with the occasion
to do very careful detective work
and to produce two maps
of the first of which we might return to.
This map is the neighborhood
of Soho in 1854.
Soho experienced at that time
an intense local outbreak
in the neighborhood
that cholera was what he called
the worst disease in the
history of the kingdom.
At the time, Soho had no sewer system.
It had no secure supply of Water
and most houses had re coursed to cesspits
and residents collected water for drinking
and for their ablutions and
buckets from a pump well
and that pump well was where
the red arrow in the map is,
in Broad Street located at
the center of the district.
Now Snow's suspicions focused on the pump.
And to test his idea he carried
out careful detective work
mapping cases of cholera,
these are spot maps,
and each of the black areas that you see
represents cases of cholera
in the neighborhood of Soho
and a number of features
clearly stood out.
The first was that the nearer
people were to the pump,
the more likely a house was
to have cases of cholera.
A second, was not people
who depended on the pump
for their drinking water
fell ill first of all.
Then there were some puzzling factors
that took quite a bit of detective work.
There were 10 puzzling cases
of people who lived nearby
and fell ill of cholera but
never took water from the pump.
But it turned out that they ate meals
at a restaurant nearby
and the restaurant served not only food,
but it's served it's diners water fresh
from the Broad Street pump.
Then there was another puzzle
was that there was a jail nearby
and somehow none of the 200 prisoners
had fallen ill with cholera again.
It turned out that in fact,
the prison brought in water
from a distance source
and so the prisoners
didn't drink water at all.
And then by an interview with
a local minister in Soho,
what John Snow learned
was a crucial further fact
that is the minister pointed into
what modern epidemiologists
might call patient zero.
It turned out that a local woman
who'd been away from the area
had contracted cholera but then recovered.
She returned to Soho with her toddler
who also fell violently ill.
She disposed of the infant's diapers
in a cesspit with porous walls
located just a few feet
from the well itself.
So Snow examined the well water
and discovered white flicks floating in it
that he thought were
the pathogenic material.
We know from modern studies
and our knowledge of the
symptomatology of cholera
that it produces the
famous rice waters stools
which are in fact, the blood plasma
being drawn out of the
the intestinal system
and along with that some of the lining
of the intestinal lumen
which actually is the white
flakes that snow discovered.
Having rapidly collected
and mapped his findings,
Snow was able to overcome
the resistance of local authorities
to try a further experiment
which was to deactivate the
suspect well in Broad Street
by removing the pump handle
and when they finally concurred,
they removed the handle
and the disease immediately ceased.
Retrospectively after this epidemic,
Snow continued his research.
This time doing detective
work in South London.
Not all of London relied
on hand pumps and wells.
Some districts were served
by private water companies.
And Snow drew up a map.
I'll leave you to imagine it.
You can just imagine a
map of the city of London
with the river coursing through
and then various areas on
the South side of the river
with different colors
for different districts
that were supplied by
different water companies.
It turns out there were two in particular,
the Lambeth Water
Company and the Southwark
and Vauxhall Water Company.
And whether you received
water from one or the other
made a tremendous difference
in what happened to you.
Let's start with the Southwark
and Vauxhall Water Company.
It serves 40,000 houses
and it yielded 1,213 cases
of cholera or 315 for
every 10,000 houses served.
The Southwork and Vauxhall Water Company
drew its water from the river towns
long after it had begun its
pathway through the city
and after the residents of London
had already disposed of
their waste in its waters.
The Lambeth company by contrast
drew its water upstream
before it had entered the city
and it produced just 98 cases
of cholera for 27,000 houses.
That is a rate of 37
for every 10,000 houses
versus 315 for the other water company.
So the impact of Snow's map
was very, very important.
The two maps marked the foundation
of the discipline of epidemiology
and showed the utility of spot maps.
They also had a very practical impact
on the sanitary movement
that was just then getting
underway in Britain.
It gave a boost to contagionism as well
although the medical
profession remained skeptical
and said this was a matter of correlation
rather than causation
and they complained that Snow had yet
to discover the actual pathogen
itself to prove his case
and that in fact, we now
know required the development
in the next generation of
microscopy as a field of research.
But Snow's hypothesis
was ultimately confirmed
by the work of Pasteur and
Robert Koch marking the triumph
of the germ theory of
disease by the 1880s.
And for our purposes a
feature that's very important
is that it demonstrated in practice
the power of map making
from medical science.
The application in fact,
of some of the tools of the humanities
in this case illustration
and storytelling.
Because that's what the maps were doing.
They were telling a narrative
to elaborating the
scientific understanding
of this deadly disease,
the most feared disease
of the 19th century.
I'm going to fast forward
and return again to the 21st century
and begin with my third map
which is that I want to talk about
which would be the next
slide if I could have that.
This is a map.
This is the one.
It's one of the 239 maps
that I warned you about.
Relax because this is the only one
I'm actually going to show you.
It had two lives and
had two very different
but powerful impacts on our country.
The first impact was during the 1930s
when these maps served the
purpose of an enormous plan
of social engineering
carried out by the New Deal
and the United States
government in the 1930s
for purposes that are now
recognized as profoundly racist.
More recently, these
maps had been resurrected
and it provided an
understanding of vital aspects
of the current coronavirus
pandemic in our country.
They have followed investigative methods,
various commentators, various
methods highly reminiscent
of Snow's methodology in the 19th century.
Now this particular map is a map
of the 1930s of Philadelphia,
And you'll note the different
colored areas on it.
The maps demonstrate that
considering these maps
is worthy of a Franke series lecture
because they bring together disciplines
that normally remain in
separate disciplinary silos.
I'm thinking of environmental
science, history,
epidemiology, and cartography.
And the maps also raise
urgent and practical questions
of politics, ethics and public health.
What lessons do we learn from
COVID-19 about its origins
and capacity to spread in our midst?
How do we learn enough both to emerge
on the other side of this pandemic
and to prepare ourselves for
future epidemic challenges
by removing the crucial vulnerabilities
that caught us so unprepared
at the start of 2020?
And then there's a
great question of ethics
and how we deal with what we learn.
A great interest in pandemics, I believe,
is that they are among other things,
great moral dramas, taking
place before our eyes
and laying bare the nature
of our relationships
to one another.
Pandemics are not random.
They reflect the nature of
the society we have built
and they travel on pathways
that we ourselves have
constructed for them
as they make their way through our midst.
If those ideas are correct
then what do we see
in this particular reflection of ourselves
that we'll see in this map?
And what ethical and political imperatives
do we feel to change the picture?
Now that we're still plunged
in the midst of our tragedy,
this may indeed be the best time
to reflect on how we got here
and what needs to change to
make our society COVID proof
for the next generation.
But first of all let's turn to the maps.
They're now fairly well-known.
This is one of the collection.
The collection was discovered
in the national archives
and they have now all been digitized
and are presently housed at
the University of Richmond
and are available online.
Their purposes and impact
have also been explored
most notably recently by Richard Rothstein
in his wonderful book, The Color of Law
and also by Ta-Nehisi Coates.
These maps were the means
to implement, as I said,
a vast program of social
engineering by the New Deal.
In other words, Franklin Roosevelt
and his administration to
combat the great depression
and boost housing construction
and to improve the living
standards of the poor
and working classes by a
redistribution of wealth.
That set up three federal agencies
that were interrelated and
all had to do with housing.
The Public Works
Administration set up in 1933,
the Homeowners Loan
Corporation of the same year
and the FHA, the Federal
Housing Administration in 1934.
These carried out an enormous
redistribution of wealth
to promote construction and home ownership
that was at this time considered
the embodiment of the American dream
and a bulwark against
possible left-wing subversion
as homeowners, it was argued,
would never risk communism
and social subversion.
But at the same time, the
Roosevelt administration
fully embraced American racial hierarchies
and intended to institutionalize
and reinforce segregation.
Billions of federal dollars were deployed
to rescue distressed white homeowners
or aspiring white homeowners
by means of cheap government
backed mortgages and insurance.
To that end the cheap
mortgages under the program
were not to be available
to African-Americans
and the maps with a means
to implement that vision.
The Homeowners Loan
Corporation commissioned maps,
therefore, of every major city
and town in the country, 239 in all
and it's just important to stress
that these were carried
out not just in the South
but in the North as well.
And this is a good example.
It's a map of Philadelphia.
In these maps, each
neighborhood of each city
was graded and shaded and
then coded for the purpose
of qualifying applicants
for mortgages and insurance.
And the coding provided
direction for the entire mortgage
and insurance industry,
banks, savings institutions,
savings and loan associations,
insurance companies.
Green earned you a grade of A.
This marked the best
neighborhoods where only whites
were intended to live
in single-family houses
and where subsidized and insured mortgages
were to be made available.
We should realize that these maps
were not simply descriptions
of what existed.
They were prescriptions of
what was intended to be.
So the next below the
green was blue graded B.
These were also to be Lily white,
but they were less desirable areas.
Lower down the yellow areas on
the map earned a grade of C,
there was somewhat
hazardous for investors.
Areas that perhaps had what
documents accompanying the maps
called, and I'm quoting here,
"unwelcome infiltrations of Negroes
"and foreign born people."
And the mixing, and I'm quoting again,
of imharmonius ethnic groupings.
And then at the bottom
there's red, the grade of D.
And this is the area
where loans, investments,
and insurance were all to
be rigidly discouraged.
The red zones gave rise
to the term redlining
but as you can see the
neighborhood divisions
are actually outlined in block
and the term therefore
is slightly appropriate.
The areas are distinguished by shading
in the relevant colors.
So the maps were proscriptive.
The color codes were intended
to regularize segregation
and housing on a permanent basis
and in fact, they were
eminently successful in that
and that's precisely what they achieved.
And the racial and
nativist vision involved
was in no way hidden.
Each map was accompanied by
a one page appraisal document
that specified that Negroes
in foreign born undesirables
were not eligible for
loans and home ownership
and that investment in the area
was officially discouraged.
Furthermore, the homes
purchased were to provide
in their property deed,
what were termed restrictive covenants.
That is clauses that in perpetuity
excluded the sale of the
property to African-Americans.
These clauses had already
been tested in 1926
before the Supreme Court
which pronounced such covenants
legal and constitutional.
So segregation was meant to be permanent
throughout the land.
And informally on a local
basis in both North and South,
attempts by African-Americans
other professional classes
to break the color wall
and to move into areas
that were not shaded in the proper color
were often met with
violence, riot, and fire
as we know, for example,
from the Cicero neighborhood of Chicago.
And this shows us that racism
isn't simply a matter of attitudes.
The whites of Cicero,
when they attacked African-Americans,
knew full well that the arrival
of an African-American
family in their midst
meant recoding of the area
and therefore a precipitous
fall in property values.
Racism, therefore was illegal
in financial structure
and not just an attitude.
But now you'll be wondering
how were the maps relevant to COVID-19.
To understand that we need to realize
that the racial segregation
engineered in the 1930s
is a structural racist vision
that persists to this very
day during the pandemic.
The Federal Reserve Bank
of Chicago, for example,
noted in a study in 1910
that the pattern of racial disparity
established by red lining was persisting
80 years after it had been first proposed
in terms of segregation,
home ownership ratios,
house values, and credit ratings.
And in fact, one could go further
than the Federal Reserve of Chicago
by saying that actually
the position had worsened
rather than improving.
That is to say after World War II
we see the great
suburbanization of America
that was funded by the GI bill
and the veterans administration.
And this again redistributed
billions of dollars
to white veterans to purchase new homes
but again not to African-Americans
however bravely they
had fought in the war.
The legal and lending
practices of the 1930s
originally confined to the cities
were now exported also to suburbia
complete with the restrictive covenants.
And we get closer to
public health and disease
by noting that the New
Deal Housing Program
and the Veteran Administration
Program after world war II
were powerful engines
of economic disparity
and the creation of poverty.
It's not by coincidence
that the wealth possessed
by the average
African-American family today
in the United States is 5%
of that owned by the average white family.
What that means is that there
has been a publicly subsidized
and persistent equity in home ownership
from the 1930s onward
that has been directed
towards particular racial
groups and denied others.
This was a decisive creator of wealth
and African-Americans were systematically
and purposefully deprived of access to it
as well as those wealth creating
mechanisms of the tax laws
that provided deductions
for mortgage payments
and the inheritance laws that
enabled accumulated wealth
to be passed with little risk
from generation to generation.
Let me give you an example.
Let me turn to the very ideal
type of the new suburbia
that emerged after World War II,
their very first great suburban community
that is Levittown and
Nassau County, New York.
There, 17,000 homes were built.
I should note too, that they
were intentionally built
by non-unionized labor
and during the construction
the builders were picketed.
They were offered in
1957 for sale at $7,990.
We can say were offered
because these houses were prefabricated.
There were assembled in 26 pieces
and each one was identical
a cape or a ranch
to all of those on the surrounding block.
So they were for sale all
at once for $7,990 each.
Made available, however,
to veterans at $400.
In 2018 the exact same prefabricated homes
were worth an average of $400,000.
So you can see the enormous
accumulation in equity
between 1957 and 2020 and
realize the way in which
the wealth of white families
was publicly subsidized
and denied to African-Americans.
As we know in the areas shaded in red,
African-Americans continued to languish
in multi-family dilapidated
inner city neighborhoods.
There were some countervailing influences.
The Supreme court in 1948
declared the restrictive covenants
a violation of the 14th amendment
and the Fair Housing Act of
1968 made red lining illegal
in the mortgage industry.
But in practice the
old structures remained
and were not dismantled.
So the former redlined neighborhoods
are today's inner city ghettos.
The very ones that were
ravaged by the coronavirus.
We could say then, that the red shadings
on the maps of the 1930s still define
the islands of vulnerability
to infectious disease
and death in 2020.
I would like to show
the last show and tell
that I'm going to present
which follows the map that I showed you.
You won't be able to see
it very well I'm afraid.
The point is that this is one
of the appraisal documents
that accompanied the maps.
Each Mount had this document along with it
explaining what the neighborhood
was meant to look like
and we'll see, for example,
this will be familiar to you all.
It's a de-rated neighborhood
in New Haven, Connecticut,
and it goes along Gulf,
Whaley and Dixwell Avenues
as far as Sherman Avenues
and in the 1930s it tells us
that the inhabitants there were domestics
and that they were predominantly Negro.
There was even a line to
tell if you were Negro
or foreign born.
That is the nativism and the racism.
It's 70% Negroes and in
growing it says infiltration.
Negroes are infiltrating the area.
And it tells us that these are houses
that are predominantly multifamily
and not a single owner occupied.
And at the bottom for clarifying remarks
it says, this is an
older section of the city
which has now given
over largely to Negroes
employed as domestics.
Dwelling from small
singles to multifamily.
This is quite congested as an area
and it gives the
appearance of a slum area.
There's an absence of market forces
that has resulted in some demolitions
and the section is subject to vandalism
and we'll see that its
prediction for the future
is that it's going to decline further
and it says, is there any
availability of mortgage?
And this was a self
fulfilling prophecy of none.
So that's just to show you
that this was a very intentional plan
and that the racial narrative
was completely built
into the structure of the plan.
The reasons for the disparities today
and vulnerability to COVID-19
are not all of course attributable
to the legacy of structural racism.
But that goes a long way to explaining
what's happening today in our midst.
Some of the sources of vulnerability
are not immediately related.
School segregation, for example,
means that houses are underfunded
and schools provide
people with the knowledge
that they need to protect themselves.
Access to medical care
has to do with insurance
or underinsurance and also
with the legacy of distrust
between the African-American community
and the medical profession
which emerged so starkly
as a result of the Tuskegee experiment.
We could talk also about
unemployment and wages,
about types of work, about diet
and the widespread presence
of obesity and diabetes
that are predisposing factors for COVID-19
and one could extend the list.
But what I would like to do is to note
how many factors are related
to what was done in the 1930s
and confirmed after World War II.
The first point is that the housing stock
in the inner cities, as we all know,
has been poorly maintained
and often unhygienic.
That there's multiple family occupancy,
multiple generation occupancy as well
and we know that COVID-19 makes its way
preferentially among elderly bodies
and also that it's a viral
disease spread by droplets
and aerosols through the air
and therefore it thrives
on conditions of density
and these are densely packed, multifamily,
multi-generational houses.
We also know that African-American homes,
these neighborhoods had
a shortage of amenities
and some actually have
been often disconnected
such as water in our country.
There's a disproportionate
number of families
without household water supplies
and therefore unable to
practice hand washing,
one of the major bits of
advice for coping with COVID-19
and also because of the
density of incapable
of practicing social distancing.
Another major factor is environmental.
And this is directly related
and built upon the social
engineering of the New Deal.
That is green and red shaded neighborhoods
actually constitute different
ecological environments.
One feature that's most
important is air pollution.
By air pollution I mean, on
the one hand greenhouse gases,
that is ground level ozone or
the various oxides of nitrogen
emitted by cars, heating, industry,
refineries, power plants,
decaying tyres, landfills
and recently here at Yale,
there's been a discovery
of the vital importance of urban land use.
That is to say in a grade A neighborhood
there were not what you
find in a green neighborhood
in a grade D red neighborhood.
You would not find the amenities
of a grade A neighborhood
in terms of large yards, parks, trees.
Instead in the inner cities,
approximately 50% of the
land is covered in asphalt
for roads, roofs, and driveways
and in the heat they emit enormous amounts
of greenhouse gases
and global warming is
making the position worse.
It's generating what
are called heat islands
in the center of the cities
that are five to 20
degrees Fahrenheit warmer
than the A rated areas were.
And an ultra fine particulate matter
generated by industry,
coal burning, wildfires,
construction, and demolition,
crumbling plaster,
and all the rest.
And it's interesting to
note the citing of industry
was in part dependent on the zoning,
the red lining of the 1930s.
That is to say that the most noxious
fuel producing industries and services
were called fence line
industries directly adjacent
to a de-rated neighborhood.
That is to say there were areas
where the land was cheaper for placement
where there were probably
highways near bond.
There were low transaction costs.
It was easy and cheap
to get zoning permission
with little opposition
from impoverished residents
with little political power.
South Philadelphia, on the
map I showed you before,
South Philadelphia is a
vast sea of red on the map
and the point is that it
was a fence line community
inhabited by African-Americans.
It's located next to
the largest oil refinery
until last year in the
East of the United States.
It has incinerators,
sewage treatment plants,
power plants, and chemical companies.
None of what you see in the
blue and white shaded areas
to the top of the map.
The NAACP set up a clean air task force
in which had noted that African-Americans
are 75% more likely to live
in a fence line community
than a white American
and that they are on average exposed
to more than 50% more air pollution
on a constant basis.
Now air pollution as a leading
cause of death worldwide.
7 million people around the
globe die prematurely every year
from the impact of air pollution
according to the World
Health Organization.
And that is more people than perish
from malaria, TB, HIV/AIDS,
and warfare all combined.
These pollution generates
stroke, asthma, heart disease,
respiratory infections,
obstructive lung diseases, cancers.
But air pollution is also a specific cause
of vulnerability to COVID-19.
A source of the very comorbidities
that lead to severe death
and to severe disease.
Fine particulate matter destroys the cilia
of the upper respiratory pathways
and it causes inflammation
in the inner respiratory trap
of bronchioles and alveoli.
And recent research has done what Snow did
which was carried out at
Harvard, in the Netherlands
and in the Nepal Valley in Italy,
they have followed Snow's mythology
of superimposing maps of COVID mortality
and morbidity over the
counties in the United States
and the administrative districts in Europe
that had the worst air pollution.
Unfortunately these maps aren't available
for public use at the moment
and so we'll just have
to imagine something
like what Snow did.
It turns out that there's
a direct correlation
just as in the case of
the Broad Street pump
and the South water
companies in South London
between these vulnerabilities
and to disease.
Particularly the infectious
disease cholera in Snow's case,
COVID-19 in ours.
And then physiological studies
are increasingly demonstrating
direct mechanisms
especially that of inflammation
that are directly related to
vulnerability to COVID-19.
So now that I'm running
rapidly out of time,
I think it would be wise to note,
with a hopeful note towards the end,
that we are waiting now for a
vaccine that will soon arrive
but I do want to make a caveat.
At the same time it's
important for us to remember
that both for COVID-19 and even
more perhaps for the future,
we need to address social
determinants of disease
that are critical to our preparedness.
This should happen in
part because it's right,
but also because the
pandemic has demonstrated
that it is also an act of
enlightened self-interest.
All of us in other words,
are in this together.
And if some communities are
at especially high risk,
everyone else will also be in danger.
Map making reminds us what
Paul Farmer has eloquently said
that medicine and public
health need to focus
not only on molecular level phenomenon
but need to give due
attention to social factors
and make structural interventions
that doctors, nurses,
and public health workers
are in fact, the natural
advocates of the poor,
the disadvantaged and
the racially oppressed.
So I think that this is
a practical public health
and a moral imperative that faces us
and I hope that as a country
even after the vaccine has done its work
will remember what got
us into the situation
in the first place
and remember that this is almost certainly
not the last challenge from viral disease
that we'll be facing
and that we need to be
prepared in the future
and not allow unnecessary
suffering and disaster
that has ravaged our
communities over this past year.
Now if people have objections or questions
that would be wonderful.
- Thank you very much for
that really thoughtful
and illuminating talk.
I think the chat is open.
Please go ahead and
type in your questions.
And I guess while we wait for that
I might just go ahead and
ask you a question myself.
I think that it is very clear
historically as you showed
that the patterns of human settlement
and socioeconomic inequalities
that undergird that
really do shape the way in
which diseases propagate.
If you could think of one
thing that we could do
as a society at the policy level,
what would it be after COVID-19?
Obviously inequities in society
and economic inequalities
have really become
much stocker in the
last couple of decades.
Do you think that it is time
now to seriously address that
because it is going to be
it would offer the backdrop
for any future pandemics or
any kinds of other catastrophes
that are not individual tragedies
but if climate change
induced catastrophes as well,
I was curious if you had
advice for policymakers
as to what would be a key intervention now
in light of what we've learned so far.
- Right.
I think that, since you've
limited me to one intervention--
- No, no, actually I take it back.
- One is fine.
I will take you at your word
and say that I would think of one
that addresses directly the issue of care
and the issue of poverty.
And that is, and I'll be
following here what Dr. Tedros,
Director General of the World
Health Organization said,
which is I then share with him the view
that perhaps the decisive intervention
is universal healthcare for everyone.
I think that addresses
the issue of poverty
and it directly addresses the
problem of widespread disease.
If I could wave my magic
wand and do one thing,
I think that would be the
number one thing that I would do
that would transform American life
and the safety of the American people.
- Thank you.
That makes total sense
that making universal access to healthcare
a basic human right that is
guaranteed by all polities.
- There are various ways to do that
and so I'm not saying exactly
which way has to be the one
but I think the point is
that everyone in the world
needs to have the human
right to healthcare
and to free access, universal
access, to that health
and that it shouldn't be
determined as a matter of profit.
- Our first question...
Go ahead, Priya.
- No, no, go ahead please.
- Sure.
Considering this issue of red lining,
concerning that it's close
to a century old now,
what do you see in our future
not just for disease but for equity?
- I feel that I don't know
what lies in our future.
I'm professionally a
forbidden, if you like,
as a historian to have a crystal ball
and say what will happen in the future.
But since you've raised the question
I will give something of a very,
who knows what will happen?
That's my first point.
Nobody knows.
And a lot will be determined
about whether as in 1918 to 19,
we decide we want to put this behind us
and not think about it anymore.
And that was the approach then.
My hope is that this has
been such a long lasting,
and will have been by the time it's over,
such a cataclysmic, economic
as well as medical crisis
that hopefully we will
be wise enough to realize
that this must not happen also
to our children and grandchildren.
We must leave a safer world for the future
that's more sustainable.
And therefore part of that
has to do with confronting
the great inequalities that
our society is built upon
that didn't arise naturally
but were part of a consciously devised
social engineering project.
It's not, I think,
which is one of the more
shocking realizations that comes
from examining these maps of the 1930s
that what they created is still
the way that we live today.
And therefore I think that
there really does need to be
maybe there's some talk.
Myself I'm a bit of, here
I'll reveal my own beliefs,
but I guess I believe in some
sort of form of green New Deal
in which we tackle environmental issues
that are critical for the
survival of the planet
and for the survival of our country
and the disadvantaged in it
and also provide employment
and all the rest for
everyone in the country
and devising new ways.
I would like to see that happen.
I suppose if I were
allowed a second magic wand
that would probably be
the thing I do second.
And we know that sometimes
genies give you three wishes.
But my genie first gave me just one
and you've given me a second.
So that's good.
- Thank you.
Another participant has mentioned
the work of cartographers
on the red lining
that you've been discussing.
He knows that there's a session,
I guess a zoom session tomorrow
by the Chicago Maps Society
on the very subject.
And I think, as I'm
reading this correctly,
a documentary has been
produced called red lined
especially on this topic.
- Let me thank the person
who suggested that.
I would love to see it.
And I'd like to know more
about the cartography involved
and who the people involved were
who actually drew up the maps.
I know who commissioned them
but I don't know who
actually produced them.
- Okay, great.
Just getting another question here.
- I think there's a question from someone
who thanks you for the amazing talk
and asks that she read somewhere
that San Francisco was
somewhat better prepared
than the rest of the country for COVID
because of their experience
with AIDS in the 1980s.
And she just wanted to ask you,
is that really true
and whether the ghost of AIDS
is haunting the COVID crisis in some way.
- I would say that there
are a couple of answers
to that question.
One of which is that I don't really know
but from what bits and pieces I do know,
I would say there's more than one piece
to that particular puzzle.
One reason is that in San
Francisco there were...
Another major driver
of disadvantaged people
in this pandemic has been the elderly
and the elderly in nursing
homes in particular
and the disease.
I would say that ageism
is also systematically
and structurally built into our system
and that the nursing homes
as the New England Journal
of Medicine piece there
just in the last few weeks said
that they were like Tinder boxes
waiting for spark to be struck.
That there were systematically unprepared
and indeed unpreparable.
The point is that San Francisco
had a number of nursing homes
that were radically different
that we're part of the imagination
of a greenhouse project
which has small nursing care centers
of perhaps 10 members
residents of a community
with nurses who actually live on site
and therefore are not going back and forth
inside the community, don't
have multiple jobs and so on.
And therefore the kind of care
and the oversight
practiced in San Francisco
were quite exceptional
in the American context.
I do believe that it is true
that a number of places
by having experienced...
And this is true not only of San Francisco
but internationally.
One of the reasons, for example, in Africa
and a number of countries there was that
they had been prepared by a
whole series of calamities
from the past, including
Ebola that we all remember
and we're in a sense ready to accept
and expect something like this or a place.
Like it was important that South Korea
had had the experience of murms.
And going back further on San Francisco
there were still community health centers
and those do really make
healthcare more accessible
to disadvantaged
communities than a huge city
with a huge urban hospital miles away
that takes a person without
a car an hour to reach
by a long bus ride.
I think those are features.
I don't believe that is in any way
an adequate answer to the question
but those are some features
that I think are parts of it.
- While we wait for more questions,
I was curious whether
you had thoughts about,
now that we do have the
prospect of multiple vaccines,
the distribution of these vaccines
and how that is going to be set up
in terms of access and equity issues.
It is also kind of front and center.
- That's absolutely correct.
And we don't quite know.
We have the CDC recommendations
of how the various tiers
that the vaccine
distribution should follow.
And we know from the CDCs announcement
that this will be months
and months and months
actually will be required
before it reaches,
let us say, you and me in the community.
So that is a very
fundamental and important
ethical and practical question.
It seems from every point of view
that the CDC recommendation is right
that healthcare workers
ought to be protected first.
We depend on them and in
some ways they're the heroes
or among the heroes of this pandemic
and they desperately need to be protected
while they carry out this work
that's essential to our whole nation.
So I accept that as a good first priority.
- Thinking historically
and with your expertise
in Italy considered,
in the cities of Europe
what were the fault lines along which
such segregation might have occurred?
- Those fault lines are sometimes
a little bit similar and reminiscent.
It is true that African-Asian
communities in Britain
very disproportionately
experienced severe disease
and mortality in Britain.
It's true elsewhere that
immigrant communities
were quite vulnerable.
But it's interesting too,
and this goes back to another feature,
which is that not everywhere
was the disease primarily
a matter of poverty.
And I think if you look at after China,
the second great, cause
you mentioned Italy,
the second great epicenter in the world
was Lombardy in the North of Italy.
And what's interesting about Lombardy
is that it was the most
prosperous region of Italy
and one of the great prosperous
regions of the world.
But there, I would say,
it was overwhelmingly
a disease of globalization
because Lombardy and China had established
a bilateral agreement in 2016
that led to enormous investment
between the two countries,
cultural exchange.
Three and a half million
Chinese tourists visited Milan
every year after the agreement was signed.
There were Chinese lessons,
there were entrepreneurs,
politicians went back and forth.
There were fairs between the two countries
exhibiting the goods of each country.
So when the epidemic broke out in China,
probably the least surprising
thing that could have happened
was that it would next
be present in Lombardy.
And there were even six airlines
that did direct flights between
the Malpensa Airport in Milan
and a number of Chinese cities.
So this movement of people,
goods services, investment
was constant and overwhelming and meant
that a disease that was infectious
and had broken out and Wuhan in one day
would be in Milan the next.
And indeed that's rather how it was.
It followed lines of housing
and multi-family occupancy
and density rather than
anything corresponding
to the American ethnicity issue.
- I guess the organization
plays a big role today
in terms of transmission of disease.
And it's very much part of it.
- Yes, in fact if I were
to be asked to define
what I'd say that disease
reflect particular stages
in the development of our societies
that we humans make.
The diseases have no agency.
We create the pathways that
pathogens find to reach us.
And I would say about this
is the first great pandemic
of the era of globalization
and that if we understand it in that way,
globalization includes
enormous international trade
and exchange, tourism, displaced people,
enormous overpopulation,
mega cities and high density,
and an includes all of
the environmental problems
that we were talking about.
Plus one would also,
that is to say about pollution
and all the rest of it
but one would also have
to invoke our relationship
with the other creatures
that inhabit our planet.
Deforestation on the
destruction of animal habitat
which if we remember
how this disease began
it's a zoonotic disease that's spread
from bats to human beings.
Now there was nothing wrong with the bats.
It was that human beings
were increasingly invading
and destroying their habitat
and came into contact with
them in ever-growing measures
and so there were
continuous spillover events
and those equal health
Alliance has been doing
a very interesting work or was
doing very interesting work
until the NIA to continue it
was cut off by our president.
But hopefully they'll
start doing it again.
And the monitoring of that situation
is quite an important one.
Part of the reason China
has played such a role
is that bats are so numerous there
and they are the reservoir
for countless viruses
and they are wonderful at
roosting in vast numbers
and transmitting the disease
to which they're immune
from one species or one member
of a fellow species to another.
And so bats are really very important.
And then of course China was important
because of its density
and those sorts of issues.
There were lots of other reasons.
Pollution is also very important there
and mega cities are important
and even the wet markets
are important there.
So there are a host of reasons
that China happened to be the
place that was first struck
none of which are equivalent to saying
it was the Chinese disease.
There was nothing about Chinese people.
It was about certain developmental
and ecological features
of the Chinese environment
that were important.
- Thank you.
Two more questions.
There have been studies that
show that some communities
that have higher mortality
are actually genetically predisposed
to be vulnerable to the virus.
Shouldn't these also be
considered a priority?
- To the extent to which
that is actually so
they clearly should be.
And here I'll have to say that
I myself don't know enough
about genetic predisposition to COVID-19
to say anything sensible about it.
So it would probably be better if I say
if I can look into that,
learn more about it,
and then I can give you an answer.
But I better not do that right now.
- From Professor Valerie Hanson
who started our series this semester.
She says, Frank, are there any instances
either in the past or with COVID
in which the disease
strikes in surprising ways?
For example, were any
rich communities hit hard
or did any localities
with non dense housing
still suffer greatly?
- Yes, there are these instances.
First thing is not this epidemic
diseases are by no means
a simple repetition of the same thing
happening again and again.
Each is entirely different.
So there are diseases
that have particularly targeted the poor.
Cholera is clearly one.
On the other hand the Spanish influenza
is probably the opposite of the disease
that struck every social class
that didn't have this
particular predisposition
but swept through entire communities.
And I would even venture
to say that COVID-19
can manifest itself in different ways
and Lombardy was a case
in which it affected
a very prosperous community
and not a very impoverished one.
So that's a clear example of that.
And we also have cases where COVID-19
began by striking in rural
communities and the Netherlands
and the Eastern agricultural
areas of the Netherlands
are an example of that.
And there have been Dutch studies of that.
And one of the features has to do
with the overwhelming air pollution.
- Let me ask one question to you.
- I was just going to
say that there is an area
of the Netherlands as a highly developed
industrialized agriculture
produces enormous amounts
of animal waste and nitrogen oxides.
So that's one of the features
that prove to be really important
in the epidemiology of that.
So it's again a bit different
from what I've been just talking about.
But yes, there are varieties
in epidemic disease
and I think that's part
of that their interests
that they reveal a lot about history
and studying them teaches a lot
about how communities are put together.
- I think that brings us to the end.
Doesn't it, Ty?
- I think so, yes.
- So I just wanted to say, thanks.
Thank you so much, Ty, for
helping with this as always.
And thank you so much, Professor Snowden,
for a wonderful talk about
really important topics
that we need to think about now.
And we are delighted
that you took the time
out of your very busy
schedule to speak to us
and we look forward to
actually treating you
and saying a big thank
you in person to you
with a very nice reception.
Here's to a virtual reception
and a promise to provide
you with a real one.
So let's all take that take time
to give him a round of applause
with either our clap buttons
or unmute ourselves and
just clap and say thank you.
Thank you very much.
So this also closes our
Franke program events
for the season.
So we look forward to
seeing you in the new year.
Meanwhile, he is wishing everyone
a very happy, healthy holiday season.
Bye.
- Thank you
- Bye, everybody.
Thank you